[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
the largest wooden ship ever built in
modern times was completed in 1909 by
the firm of percy and small in bath
maine
they named it the wyoming because
governor brooks of wyoming was one of
the chief investors
the odd thing is wyoming is a landlocked
state with no ocean port
then again wyoming is a very big state
and this ship was enormous
it was a six masted schooner with a
length of 450 feet from tip to tip
this made the wyoming the largest wooden
ship ever built
her six masts towered 120 feet above the
deck and they flew 12 000 yards of sail
to build the hull alone required a
virtual forest of one and a half million
feet of pine
and the wyoming was a workhorse that
could carry 6000 tons of coal
but because of her extreme length in the
wood construction the wyoming tended to
flex and creak in heavy seas causing the
long planks to twist
allowing seawater to leak in the hold
the colossal ship had to use pumps
constantly to keep her hold free of
water
after 15 years of service in march 1924
the wyoming floundered and sank in a
heavy storm
with all hands
you know the bible says there was
another wooden boat about the same
dimensions as the wyoming built by
craftsmen that had never been to sea
and yet it survived the worst storm in
history
i'll give you two guesses pastor ross
what boat we're talking about
i think we all know we're talking about
noah's ark which interestingly enough
it's very close to the size of uh the
wyoming that's right probably not as
wide definitely not as you know the the
arc was much higher and different
directions
i think they just had a picture on the
screen of the arc encounter you and i
were there in uh i forget where it's at
in kentucky yeah
and that's quite a and it's supposed to
be built to scale yes but then that's
quite an experience but uh according to
the bible the ark was 300 cubits long 50
cubits wide 30 cubits high uh with a
qubit using 18 inches
that would be 450 feet so it's the same
length as the wyoming but it's kind of
cheating a little because the wyoming is
going from the the bow sprit to the
the back
pole
off the back
and uh with the ark was 75 feet wide 45
feet high
so
yeah it was a a much bigger boat but it
survived the storm
you mentioned something before we went
on the air i thought that was
interesting
is that um
all of the animals before the flood that
survived were on the ark
and the animals that did not survive
were on the wyoming because they had
become cold that's right and the wyoming
was a coal carrier
you want to be a noah's ark if you're
the animal for sure that's right well
you know this reminds me of a verse that
jesus shares in matthew chapter 24 and
this is verse
37-39 but as the days of noah were so
also will the coming of the son of man
be
for as in the days before the flood they
were eating and drinking marrying and
giving in marriage until the day that
noah entered the ark and they did not
know until the flood came and took them
all away
so it will be with the coming of the son
of man seems to indicate pastor ross
that
it's going to seem like life's going on
with some normalcy when
the end finally hits
of course the ark was built and then all
the animals entered into the ark and
that probably stirred people up but then
the door was closed and it seemed as
though things just kept going on the
same for the next seven days a matter of
fact the people outside the ark probably
began to mock noah and his family inside
the ark but then suddenly the sky grew
dark and the flood came yeah absolutely
and he warns us that you know in the
last days evil men and seducers will wax
worse and worse
and just because it looks like life is
going on it says before the flood
they were eating and drinking marrying
had planning marriages usually looking
forward when you plan a marriage
they were planting they were building
those are things the person does when
they're looking forward
and then boom it's like sodom and
gomorrah when they woke up that morning
um it was a beautiful day you know birds
were tweeting from flower to flower and
and uh
i guess the birds were going from branch
to branch the butterflies were going to
the flowers plus the hummingbirds yeah
but then after lot and his family got
out it says god rained down fire and
brimstone
so jesus warns us that when the end
comes it's going to come suddenly
and
there's not going to be an airplane
writing it in the sky
but we see some of the same signs
happening in the world today
we do have a book that talks about end
time events and it's it's called the
last night on earth and it talks about
this passage of scripture as well as
others how can we be ready for what is
yet to come this is our free offer for
this evening if you'd like to receive it
all you have to do is call the number
800-835-6747
and you want to ask for offer number 101
again it's called the last night on
earth and we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks it's
800-835-6747
as for the last night on earth we'll be
happy to put it in the mail if you're
north america if you're outside of north
america please just go to the amazing
facts website just amazingfacts.org
you'll be able to read the book right
there online if you have a bible
question i see a number of folks already
called in and they're waiting but if you
have a bible question the number to call
is
800-463-7297 that's
800-463-7297 i know these folks watching
on the internet also on good news tv and
then also on facebook yep incidentally
we might want to just mention if you're
watching on facebook pastor doug's
facebook page also the amazing facts
facebook page if you have a bible
question you can type it there in the
comment section and at the end of the
program you're going to try and answer
uh the questions that have already come
in
on our facebook page so you can do that
all right we'll have prayer and we'll go
to that let's do that dear father in
heaven again we thank you for your word
thank you for the opportunity that we
have to be able to study the bible
together and we do ask for the holy
spirit to be with us here in the studio
and those who are listening wherever
they are
we ask this in jesus name amen
amen first caller that we have this
evening is from the virgin islands we
have a sahaya
sahaya welcome to the program
i um good evening it's actually shia
shia welcome
yeah
uh thank you so uh my question is
how was the idea of limbo created
yeah now the the the teaching of limbo
is not found in the bible the teaching
of limbo is a construct that has come
from
a roman catholic theology
and it's it's uh describing sort of an
in-between world between heaven and hell
um
where souls are kept and to be honest
with you i've not studied limbo in depth
because i don't find it in the bible i
like to spend most of my time
studying the true and not kind of
manufactured teachings as with purgatory
purgatory is another teaching where
supposedly in the catholic church you
you die but you know because heaven is
holy and for you to get to holy you need
to go through a purging and so you go
through this fiery
experience of purgatory to prepare you
for heaven
so those teachings aren't in the bible
and i think the catholic church has
actually abandoned the teaching of limbo
i could be wrong but i thought i read a
few years ago that they no longer teach
that
all right well thank you for your call
we've got martha who's listening in
california and martha welcome to the
program
thank you pastors um
for taking my call
um
my question is uh based on genesis 2 7
some of my friends you know believe that
when you die your soul goes to heaven
but after reading
genesis 2 7 which says
and the lord god formed man of the dust
of the ground
and breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life and man became a living
soul
that gives me the impression
that once a person dies and the breath
of life is gone that the soul
ceases to exist is that correct
yeah essentially you could look at it in
these terms the bible tells us and the
word
the word uh
soul there
uh or rather spirit or breath it's it's
talking about pneuma well in the greek
it's roa i'm sorry in the hebrew it's
in the greek it's numa is the word they
both mean breath
and
bible tells us in ecclesiastes 12 that
when a person dies you basically have
creation in reverse
it says that the body returns to the
earth as it was and the spirit or the
breath of life returns to god who gave
it
so
right now we think and function and
operate because
we have this gift of life this breath of
life and it functions in our bodies we
experience life in our bodies our brains
even dream in our bodies
when you die
you know who you are basically is kind
of
it's the programming that god has he
saves that and he's gonna in the
resurrection he kind of puts it all in a
new body we don't uh we don't go to
heaven with the old bodies flesh and
blood cannot inherit the kingdom of god
so we have a special study guide that
actually deals with the subject of death
and it's got all the verses that explain
uh the breath of life and we'll be happy
to share a copy with you our study guide
is called are the dead really dead and
all you have to do to receive that is
just call
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide are the dead really dead we'll be
happy to send that to anyone in north
america you know pasadena we also have a
website called
deathtruth.com
and if you want to go to that website
it's got a number of verses there's
actually sermons you can watch there a
lot of great resources just
deathtruth.com
martha thank you for your call we've got
craig listening from washington craig
welcome to the program
hello thank you
you guys uh yeah i just want to say you
guys have been inspirational to me and
i thank you so much for your work well
it's a joy to do it thank you so much
for your uh encouragement craig and your
question tonight
yeah it was on revelation 19 10 um where
it says um
that the testimony of jesus christ is
the spirit of prophecy
yes and
and i hear all the time
the gift of prophecy rather than the
spirit of prophecy
and
i was just wondering because
when i read john 6 63
it's um it says it is the spirit who
gives life
the flesh prophets nothing the words
that i speak to are spirit in their life
and you're you know what does that mean
but you go back through john
john 2 3 4
but john 2 says jesus said to them
destroy this temple and in three days i
will raise it up then the jews said
it has taken 46 years to build this
temple and you will raise it up in three
days
but he was speaking of the temple of his
body
and so
um
you know jesus uses literal things like
the temple and applies him in an
illustrative application to other
literal things like his body
and that's the spirit right
of his language
and so when it says
the testimony of jesus what he says is
the spirit of prophecy
and in prophecy you got babylon which is
not
literal babylon
the city but it's
the false religious system
and you got all kinds of you know israel
there's nothing literal israel but
spiritual israel
and so i'm just wondering
um
you know is that
could that be
what it's talking about or is it
well let's talk about that for a second
um
you know when you read there in
revelation first of all you look in
revelation 12 and the last verse and it
says and the dragon was wroth with the
woman and he went to make war with the
remnant of her seed that keep the
commandments of god and have the
testimony of jesus
and so you wonder what is the testimony
of jesus
well you go to revelation 19 there in
verse 10 the angel tells john the
testimony of jesus is the spirit of
prophecy
well that goes along with isaiah chapter
where it talks about the law and the
prophets you can read that in isaiah 8
16 and you can read it in isaiah 8 20
where it tells us to the law and the
testimony if they do not speak according
to this word it's because there's no
light in them i would not over
complicate it if i were you craig
because
it's simply talking about the law and
the prophets there
it says the woman keeps the commandments
of god and it's the testimony of jesus
and you know one of the gifts of the
spirit is prophecy
so calling it a gift or calling it the
spirit of prophecy they're kind of
interchangeable it's the holy spirit
that gives the gift of prophecy
so it's basically just saying these two
characteristics of god's church in the
last days that she's got the law and the
prophets she has the truth the gifts of
prophecy and obedient commandment
keeping you know the verse i think you
referred to pastor ephesians 4 verse 11
speaking about the church and what the
spirit gives to the church and he
himself speaking of the spirit gave some
to be apostles and some prophets so one
of the gifts given by the holy spirit to
the church is the gift of prophecy also
known as the spirit of prophecy or the
testimony of jesus it also says that now
first corinthians chapter 12 it's one of
the gifts is the the holy spirit is
prophecy now we have a book that talks
about the two witnesses the law and the
prophets
and it references this first we'll send
you a free copy i think it's called the
glorious mount who are the two witnesses
if you'd like to receive that all you
have to do is call once again our
resource number that's 800-835-6747
ask for the book on the two witnesses
called the glorious mount and we'll be
able to send that to anyone who calls
and asks
we have uh josiah listening from new
york josiah with the program
josiah you might be on mute you're there
josiah
i know sometimes people patiently wait
and they they put it on mutant that's
the smart thing to do
and your question
are you there um yeah i'm here i'm here
okay your question tonight
yes um
my question is um
would it be inconsistent
with god
if he had said something right in the
old testament
then later on
change it in the new testament for
example
we have the sabbath right
yep
then
another one is
as a seventh-day adventist we say that
um
god savage to still exist till today
then
it's because well god does not change
when you read um malachi 3 verse
6 in the book of hebrew 13 the 8th
chapter
so um
in term of my question is in term of who
israel is
would it be inconsistent
if god said true israel was the people
from
from the
from the um from abraham isaac and jacob
and the defendant of jacob who later on
become israel
so
he was dealing with them
then why today the church is teaching
that
true israel is every anybody who accept
christ okay let's let's talk about that
so god says i am the lord i change not
and then you read in hebrews i think you
quoted it was a chapter 13 jesus christ
the same yesterday today and forever
and if god called abraham
and the jewish nation and said that he
was going to bless the world through
them
then why would god suddenly change and
say now israel is the church
well
the descendants of abraham have always
been
the church in other words he's not
changing in that
what's happening is
even in the old testament just because
you had jewish blood didn't mean you
were holy and you were going to be saved
there were good descendants of abraham
and there were some that were they
behaved very badly
the apostles and jesus of course were
descendants of abraham and the people
that killed jesus that handed him over
were also descendants of abraham
jesus said to the religious leaders
you say you're children of abraham
you're not of your children of abraham
you are of your father the devil now
those were the the enemies that were
fighting against the truth then paul
tells us in romans he says he is not a
jew which is one outwardly but he is a
jew which is one inwardly and that
circumcision is not in the flesh it's of
the spirit and if then in galatians paul
says if you are christ you are abraham's
seed so it's always been true old and
new testament that those who came to god
and believed even in the mosaic laws as
the stranger that accepts the lord
he was considered he was adopted into
the family he was grafted in
and then if you had people that were
literally children of abraham or israel
and they were disobedient they died in
the wilderness they didn't make it to
the promised land so god's terms of
salvation have always been for those who
follow him that's his true family that's
always been those who are the spiritual
descendants of abraham
so now we have a book that's called
spiritual israel that will explain this
perfectly josiah we'll be happy to send
you a free copy and the number again is
800-835-6747 you can ask the book it's
called spiritual israel we'll be happy
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
next quarter that we have is ginger
listening in nebraska ginger welcome to
the program
hello
hi thank you for calling
my question is are angels only in human
form or are angels in different living
forms and what is a good bible verse on
angels
okay good question
uh do angels only appear in human form
or can angels appear in other ways
well you know it seems like an angel
spoke through a donkey in the story of
balaam and that would be a good angel
and it seems like a bad angel spoke
through the
serpent in the garden of eden and that
would be the devil
and so
can angels speak through or manipulate
other creatures
you also have a story where
some angels some demons filled a herd of
pigs and the pigs went berserk and ran
off a cliff
so
whether they took the form of pigs
you know i don't know the bible does say
concerning the devil and i think this is
in second corinthians 11 it says satan
himself is transformed
into an angel of light so angels have
some ability maybe to
transform their appearance
and that's why we've got to be careful
because some fallen angels have
sometimes pretended to be the spirits of
dead people to manipulate others
so i don't know what do you think pastor
yeah we have the example for example
of um
let's say as king saul that went to the
witch of endor and an evil spirit
impersonated the prophet samuel that's
right at least it appeared that it was
samuel so there you have an evil spirit
you know trying to take the place or
represent a deceased loved one
and yeah it does seem as though they can
at least take possession of animals
you mentioned the pigs and others yeah
the serpent of course there's a dragon
in the book of revelation described as
the devil too but it's interesting yeah
powerful beings there's good ones and
bad ones now ginger i've got a message
online you can watch for free on youtube
and it's just uh the truth about angel
so you can type in doug batchelor
amazing facts and we've got a couple of
messages that go into depth talking
about angels
okay thank you we've got robert
listening in washington robert welcome
to the program
oh thank you pastor ross
and your question tonight
yes it's about i was reading in matthew
chapter 5
about describing the pharisees and
how
uh
let's see
unless you've got their righteousness
unless you exceed their righteousness
then you won't be able to make it into
the kingdom of heaven
really
right
and they were really rigorous and and
just had always uh
hundreds or thousands of rules kind of
thing
so um
is it easy to get into the kingdom of
heaven or is it hard
okay good question is it hard or easy to
get into the kingdom of heaven
by the way before we even answer this
question i don't want to forget to let
you know we have a book and i don't
think we've offered it before but it's
in our lineup of
free offers
is it easier to be saved or lost a great
book by joe cruz
people automatically think well straight
as a gate narrows away
it's hard to be saved
but in reality it's it's only going to
be a few number because few actually
look
the bible says the way of the
transgressor is hard jesus said take my
yoke upon you my yoke is easy my burden
is light it's much easier to be saved
and to serve jesus than to serve the
devil the devil's like the pharaoh he is
a hard taskmaster
now when it says here in matthew chapter
5 verse 20 i say to you unless your
righteousness exceeds the righteousness
of the scribes and pharisees you'll by
no means be saved when christ said
unless it exceeds their righteousness he
didn't mean you needed to be more
fastidious
and exacting than the scribes and
pharisees he meant you needed to have a
better quality of righteousness they
were trusting their own righteousness we
are trusting a higher righteousness it
is the righteousness of christ
now they were trusting and outward jesus
is saying you must have inward
change it's not just your outward
actions it's your inward attitude in
your spirit
so
uh yeah i wasn't saying we needed to be
more legalistic than the scribes and
pharisees he said you needed a better
quality
than they had
so uh yeah go ahead and uh make sure and
call us for that book is it easier to be
saved or lost robert and you'll be
blessed the number is 800-835-6747
as for the book is it easier to be saved
or to be lost and we'll send it out to
to you robert or anyone who calls and
asks time for one more before the break
all right i think we have jeff in
montana jeff welcome to the program
good evening
is the instruction of the law in
deuteronomy 24 3 and 4 still apply today
and specifically in the case of
abandonment in the first marriage
and would the abomination before the
lord be because of being with another
partner or being married to another
because wasn't hosea instructed to take
back his wife after she had been with
another
but not mary
yeah good good question first of all
for our friends listening well let me
read the verse and then i'll answer as
well as i can it says here in
deuteronomy 24 i'll start with verse 3
well if a man divorces a woman and it
says if the latter husband she remarries
if her latter husband detests her and
writes her certificate of divorcement
and puts it in her hand sends her out of
his house or if the latter husband dies
who took her his wife then her former
husband who divorced her must not take
her back to wife as she's been defiled
for this is an abomination before the
lord
uh he said that uh basically you know
this could start growing what do you
call it could descend into kind of wife
swapping
uh here you marry you for a while and
that doesn't work out then i'll marry
her back again
so you know the bible bible's clear god
wants marriage to be permanent and
if heaven forbid there is a divorce
it's divorce is not so you could try it
out with someone else and that doesn't
work out then you go back
now what happened with hosea and let me
just back up sometimes a man or woman
will have an affair and those marriages
can be redeemed be very clear about that
and the lord tells us that he's
forgiving
god tells hosea to marry a harlot that's
not normally what he tells religious
leaders to do
this was to be an illustration a living
illustration of how god was willing to
love and take back the church his bride
even though she had been unfaithful many
times and gone after idols
and when she was unfaithful again he
said take her back again to illustrate
that even after
many
uh times of being a repeat offender the
church has wandered from god god
forgives her and he takes her back it's
the history of not only israel but the
history of the church
and of course this specific uh law that
we find in the old testament jesus
comments on this in matthew chapter 19
speaking to the religious leaders about
the certificate of divorce he says moses
said this because of the hardness of
your hearts
so this was not god's plan at least not
in the beginning but because of their
stubbornness and the hardness of their
hearts he allowed
that that law the certificate of divorce
so in one sense yeah it's it's true that
god was trying to without a doubt limit
or help people to recognize the
sacredness of marriage it was to be a
long uh you know a lifelong commitment
but even that was plan b plan a was for
them to remain married as jesus brings
it out
yeah god doesn't want his his people
going from uh
a man and woman being married and they
say we're having difficulties i think
i'll go try and marry this other person
oh that didn't work out i'll come back
and marry you again
and basically saying that
some people start thinking the grass is
greener on the other side of the fence
and god created this law to prevent
people from ever thinking i'll try that
and then i can come back they needed no
marriage was permanent and divorce was
permanent and it's a very very serious
matter
so listening friends all right don't go
away we've got more bible questions
coming
and don't forget you can also take a
look at our website during the break
amazingfacts.org a lot of the offers can
be found there as well
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
are you looking for a simple way to
share your faith
if you've ever found yourself
tongue-tied when trying to explain what
the bible teaches about the sabbath the
second coming or the afterlife
you'll love the new amazing facts tracks
these colorful tracks feature easy to
read type and are large enough to grab
everyone's attention but small enough to
fit in your pocket to carry with you
wherever you go
eleven key bible teachings are available
now purchase a sample bundle to see what
fits your needs then buy them in bulk
and save
equip yourself and your church to reach
your community with the eye-catching
amazing facts tracks
amazing facts tracks easy to read easy
to share
to order your sample bundle call
800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
and get ready to share your faith like
never before
okay friends let's start with the basics
we know we're here
but we're not here for very long so the
most important thing would be if we
could learn during this life how to live
forever this is the central focus of
amazing facts now there's a lot of
wonderful things that christian
ministries do i believe in christian
education but if the schools lose the
message of salvation
you end up with more educated sinners
i think it's very important for us to
build churches
but if the churches lose the message of
salvation they just become buildings and
shells
i think it's important to have a medical
ministry and build hospitals but if they
separate that from the message of
salvation you just prolong a sinner's
life for a little while that's why for
years amazing facts has made it our
focus to present the saving truth that
sets people free and friends we want to
thank you for your support and your
gifts we'll do our very best to convert
those resources into the currency of
heaven may god bless you and keep
amazing facts in your prayers
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's
now 800-463-7297 rejoin our hosts for
more bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and if you've got bible
questions then give us a call this is a
live interactive international bible
study and you can call the number 800
god says or
800-463-7297 and we will search the word
together for the answers
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross and we've got barbara who is
listening in tennessee barbara welcome
to the program
hi thanks for taking my call
the bible says that the punishment for
sin is death and of course christ died
on the cross and took that punishment
justifying us
but what about his suffering did his
suffering in any way contribute to our
justification i'm sorry did his
justification and
or sanctification
yes and i was i'm sorry go ahead
i'm sorry and i was actually looking at
first peter 2 24.
all right well let me read that for our
friends who are watching it says in
first peter chapter 2 verse 24 who
himself bore our sins in his own body on
the tree that we having died to sin
might live for righteousness by whose
stripes you were healed
so uh what about his suffering we know
the penalty for sin is death but that
that statement is actually a summary the
penalty for sin is not just death the
penalty for sin is punishment according
to your works
and death
so jesus not only died on the cross it's
not like they you know jesus they just
flipped a switch and jesus went to sleep
jesus suffered and died the suffering
was the punishment for our sins
there are varying degrees of reward
for both
obedience and service and sacrifice and
also for sin and disobedience
jesus said that he that knew his
master's will
and did not do it will be beaten with
many stripes
he that did not know his master's will
and didn't do it will be beaten with few
stripes
so
to be
really honest the penalty for sin is not
just
dying like you close your eyes and it's
for eternal darkness it's suffering
and death
and so jesus suffered for our sins on
the cross
we also the verse in revelation chapter
22 says that when jesus comes he brings
his rewards with him to give to every
man according to their works that's
right so there is a degree and of course
that does involve suffering for the
wicked it's amazing you read for example
in the bible you read about the garden
of gethsemane and what jesus went
through
where it seems if the angel did not come
and strengthen him he would have died
right there just bearing the weight of
the sins of the world
there was amazing incredible suffering
more than we can ever imagine where
jesus said my god my god why is that
forsaking me so that was very real it
was it was christ bearing our sins so
yeah jesus experienced both mental and
physical suffering taking
our punishment
and one more thought on that barbara is
there's the parable of matthew 18 where
this unmerciful servant he owes this
incredible debt to the king king
forgives him
but then he refuses to forgive a fellow
servant and has his fellow servant
punished for a little debt
the king says your forgiveness is
revoked to the wicked servant and he
says you are now going to the tormentors
to pay your debt
so there is punishment for sin
all right next quarter the behalf is
also listening in tennessee we have jeff
in chattanooga tennessee jeff welcome to
the program
hi pastors thank you for taking my call
i appreciate it
yes sir i was
just kind of wondering
um
when a person loses a spouse
and possibly remarries years down the
road
um how does that play out on
resurrection day
is it feasible for that person to end up
with two spouses
well you know your question and maybe
pastor ross will look at that where the
sadducees ask jesus a very similar
question
they put a
they put a proposition to jesus of a
scenario where this woman
marries a man and and he dies before her
and so according to the old hebrew law
his brother took her in and marries her
and then he dies
and then she marries another brother and
he dies and i guess she goes through
seven brothers they all die
and then she dies eventually from old
age
and
i wouldn't marry her after you know the
third or fourth guy dies i think she's
bad luck but anyway so this is the
illustration that they gave jesus and
they said who is she married to in the
resurrection
and jesus said to them you do air now
did you have the verse yes matthew
chapter 22
verse the answer jesus answers verse 29
jesus answered and said to them you're
mistaken not knowing the scripture or
the power of god for in the resurrection
they neither marry nor given in marriage
but are like the angels of god in heaven
right
so
it seems like in heaven you know one of
the reasons god has marriage and
procreation he said be fruitful and fill
the earth you know god wants us to have
a loving relationships with everybody
but there was something unique about
marriage relationships
now does that mean that when adam and
eve get to heaven assuming they're both
saved that god gives them divorce papers
not necessarily i mean people who are
married to their best friend
what would prevent them from being best
friends in heaven
and there are going to be pleasures in
heaven that will far outweigh any
physical pleasure of marital intimacy
that paul says you can't even imagine
the things that god has prepared for
those that love him and so no one's
going to get to heaven and feel like
that they've lost out if you want to be
with your former spouse
then you know by all means you know i've
often thought about when when uh king
david will be in heaven
sounds like uriah will be in heaven he
was a faithful soldier worship god
bathsheba
sounds like she'll be in heaven
and so
that's going to be an interesting
reunion if you know the story because
david had uriah killed to take his wife
and they're all going to be in heaven
because they all repented and
be strange so who's david married to
who's uriah married to probably you know
not going to be married to anybody they
can just be friends with their friends
all right well thank you cole uh you
know the bible does say that i has not
seen not yet heard neither is it entered
into the heart of man the things that
god is preparing for those that love him
sometimes you speak to young people and
they think well i don't want jesus to
come just yet i haven't had a chance to
get married yeah well no you won't be
disappointed when you get to heaven for
sure that's right we've got oscar
listening listening in new york oscar
welcome to the program
yes sir thank you
i would like to understand salvation
i was talking to a man and he told me
that
if we have a choice then god will not be
in complete control
so my question is do we have a choice or
do we respond to god
when it comes to salvation
well you absolutely have a choice
because that's why
joshua said choose you this day who you
will serve
and jesus said
whosoever believes in me
shall not perish but have everlasting
life
you know the only way that we can love
god is because we have a choice if we
are pre-programmed or forced to love god
it stops being love it's just we become
robots that are just repeating i love
you god i love you god
and it's like we'd have no choice
but love must be freely given
it must be an intelligent choice
and so
you know
nothing is more important than the
exercise of the will and god has given
humans a free will so absolutely we can
choose to follow jesus some chose yes
and some chose no some started out yes
and then they changed their mind some
started out saying no
like the boys in the parable and then
one repented and said i will follow you
i will do my father's will
so
yeah we are free moral agents that can
choose
yes we mentioned the book a little
earlier can a saved man choose to be
lost well that deals with that same
subject yeah please order that oscar
it's free the number to call is
800-835-6747 you can ask the book can i
save man choose to be lost and it deals
with the subject of predestination what
does the bible teach on that
we've got kelly listening in utah kelly
welcome to the program
hi
yes thank you um
i have a question that has to do with
two
bible verses the first one is
psalm 5 4 that says
for thou art not a god that has pleasure
in wickedness neither shall evil dwell
with thee
and then i'm looking at job
2 where it says
once again the sons of god came to
present themselves before the lord and
satan also came with them
and the lord said to satan once do you
come
and satan answered the lord and said
from roaming the earth and patrolling it
i'm just wondering how is
satan able to be in the
presence of god if he's evil
yeah
yeah especially after you read
psalm
5 and verse 4.
well i don't think that the devil abides
in the presence of god i don't think the
devil enjoys the presence of god the
bible tells us that satan claims to be
the prince of this world of course we
know that the devil was in the presence
of jesus when he came to tempt him
and we know there was a war in heaven
where michael and his angels threw out
the devil and his angels
but satan has claimed this world because
adam and eve surrendered dominion when
they chose to obey the devil and so
whenever these heavenly leaders get
together as you have in
revelation 5 and in the book of job
chapter 1
i think it's job 1 and 2
that satan comes saying he's a
representative of the earth
i don't think he abides in his heaven i
don't know how close he gets to god's
presence but he comes close enough to
make accusations
so
i don't know if that's answering your
question kelly does that make sense
um yeah it's just kind of like
me for instance i can't be in the
presence of god because of my sin
but
um
and i guess you know i'm still able to
talk to god and stuff like that but
i guess just wondering how satan
um i guess
well keep in mind that
you and i can't we can't see good angels
and we can't see bad angels unless
there's a rare manifestation sometimes
good angels and bad angels might appear
but um
we're physical creatures we kind of lost
our spiritual dimension with sin
uh the the devil is a spirit the bible
says we wrestle against not flesh and
blood but spiritual powers in heavenly
places and so as a spirit then jesus
says god is spirit those that worship
him must worship him in spirit and truth
there's a whole different world that's
going on out there that we've kind of
lost contact with so it's hard for me to
to identify with that but it is
different i think for humans than it is
for angels
all right well thank you thank you very
much kelly we've got linda listening in
california linda welcome to the program
good evening pastors
yeah
my question
is psalms
91 1
it talks about the secret place of the
most high
how do we dwell in that secret place
what is that secret place
well that is a good question
you know i think that what it's
describing here is the spirit-filled
life
paul talks about those who are in christ
and when we surrender our lives and we
experience a new birth we can live lives
where we are in communion with god we're
walking with god like enoch
that we are living in trust paul had
that experience where he said i've
learned in whatever state i am to be
content you know i'm totally in god's
will whatever god wants to do with me is
his business because i am
in
god so to speak
and so what do you think pastor ross
what is this absolutely well you know i
think it also refers to a special time
of communion with god we know that jesus
arose early in the morning and he spent
time in prayer without a doubt he spent
time reading and studying and i think if
we do that on a regular basis every day
take some time
spend time in his words spend time in
prayer we are dwelling in that secret
place of power
where the spirit of god is working in
our hearts and in our lives and that is
a place of peace that is a place of joy
it becomes our fortress in a world of
sin and that's how a person lives a
victorious life so i think that's also
part of dwelling in the secret place of
the most high
amen all right thank you and that's a
good answer it's also your personal
devotions is another way to be in that
secret place next quarter that we have
is um
tavis vision tavision from illinois
television welcome to the program they
say beyond tavion sorry
there you go pastor all right
no you're fine but um
but no so essentially my um question is
in regards to deuteronomy not
deuteronomy
my word
numbers uh 31
uh versus like it's the last two verses
if i remember correctly um
was seven no it was uh verse 18.
um and it's essentially regarding to um
essentially regarding into where the
israelites were to go into
uh the land if i remember correctly
and essentially those essentially those
who were committing adultery or who had
slept with a man they were to be killed
and i believe it was the sons and the
males were to be killed but the wives
were to be
uh left alive for yourselves
like like i'm quite certain that's not
like saying in a sense that they
promoted um like sexual slavery but
rather like what does it mean
all right yeah good question and these
are tough times you know and moses is
giving a law here regarding war
and sometimes they when one nation
fought against another nation
they didn't want to keep fighting that
battle they would annihilate them
but god told moses he said look
um
if you go to war with your enemy
the the boys might grow up and want
vengeance everyone believed that you had
a a blood feud forever if your parents
or grandparents were killed by nation
they were forever your enemies so they
would often annihilate all the soldiers
and the males
and the women who were married
but the the young ladies that were not
married
they could be
eligible to be saved and be wives
in israel they were treated with the
respective wives they were not treated
like
sex slaves as you said
so
you know that was the um
that was this kind of some of the
barbari
barbaric
times in which they lived
and of course part of it as you
mentioned past the doug is in order for
israel to preserve a true faith and true
worship
they had to
limit the influence that the pagan
nations around them would have on them
and if there was not this type of
cleansing of the land and of course even
though that happened we still see israel
drifting back into idolatry and
following the customs of the pagan
nations it would have been so much worse
if if they had allowed those nations to
remain yeah and one more thing in that
verse that you're asking about
this is dealing with a battle against
the moabites
and the moabite women had gone in among
the men to seduce them into idolatry and
if you look a little earlier moses says
in verse 16 look these women caused the
children of israel through the council
of balaam to trespass against the lord
in the incident of pure where there was
a plague among the congregation of the
lord now kill every male among the
little ones and kill every woman who has
known a man because some of those women
who had gone in to seduce the men and
lead them into idolatry but he said you
can spare the
the maidens that were on betrothed so
there was this was connected with
an actual event where those women had
seduced the men of israel into sin
all right thanks for your call we've got
charles listening in uh somerset
california charles welcome to the
program
hey great talking to you guys
wondering
i was wondering where the authority
comes from to use the day your principle
in daniel 8 14
when the original hebrew word yom
strong's number 317
uh or day is not in that text
that for your audience is the uh
word used in numbers and ezekiel which
god allows to be translated into years
but it's not in daniel 8 14.
those those words are irregular
yep let's talk about it
um now in this this is a prophecy about
the um
2 300 days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed
and
some places says 2000 evenings and
mornings
and it's talking about the day of
atonement once a year on the day of
atonement they had this special ceremony
so whether you say you apply
the day for the year
principle
that would be 2 300 years or if you say
2 300 days of atonement well the day of
atonement only came once a year so
you're saying 2 300 days of atonement
that's 2 300 years you end up with the
same
the same uh answer either way and maybe
pastor ross has something to add yeah
you know the actual expression itself
literally translated as evening morning
or evenings mornings
well there's only one morning and one
evening every day so if there's 2300
evening and 2300
mornings well that would mean there's
2300 days we also see a very similar
description
in genesis
the evening and the morning with the
first day right the same kind of idea so
there's a clear connection between the
word evening mornings to an actual
24-hour period or a day yeah and for the
jews they had in a day they would have
the morning and the evening sacrifice so
it's describing a day and it's connected
with the sanctuary either way whether
you say it's 2 300 days of atonement or
2 300 days and a day is a year in
prophecy
the prophecy and the other thing is
it only works that way
if you say that the
the 2300 day prophecy in daniel 8 14
if there are literal days
each 2 300 days
doesn't reach to any event that fills
the prophecy but if you do 2 300 years
it certainly does
so it also fits that's one more argument
right right and we see some consistency
throughout these various numbers in the
book of daniel referring to one
prophetic days of the one literally yeah
also in revelation
all right thanks for your call we got
linda listening in arizona linda welcome
to the program
thank you how are you doing this evening
we're blessed
likewise
i am conflicted um
concerned in romans 7 19
through 25
and i associated with seth
sabotage and
it was when paul was speaking
because
i have been filled with the holy spirit
but
i have not gained obedience and i have
had the holy spirit since 2003
and i've always struggled with that it's
like a spiritual warfare within so can
you please explain
romans 7
19-25
all right well let me read this i may
not be able because we've only got a few
minutes may not be able to unpack all of
it but let me read verses 19 and 20
for the good that i will to do i do not
but the evil that i do not that i
practice now if i do that which i will
not it's no longer i but sin that dwells
in me
so i find that a law of evil is present
with me the one who wills to do good for
i delight in the law according to the
inward man but i see another law at war
in my members
making war bringing me in captivity to
the law of sin which is in my members
then he asks a question verse 24 oh
wretched man that i am who will deliver
me from the body of this death talking
about this the
lust and the problems of the flesh the
answer is i thank god through the lord
jesus christ so then with my mind i
serve the law of god but with the flesh
the law of sin you have to read the next
verse in chapter eight
there is now no condemnation to those
who are in christ jesus who do not walk
according to the flesh but according to
the spirit
for the law of the spirit of life in
christ jesus has made me free from the
law of sin and death for what the law
could not do in that it was weak through
the flesh
god did by sending his own son in the
likeness of sinful flesh on account of
sin he condemned sin in the flesh that
the righteous requirement of the law
might be fulfilled in us who do not walk
according to the flesh but according to
the spirit
so
when you're filled with the holy spirit
for one thing don't be discouraged
thinking well that means i'll never sin
again.
one thing the holy spirit does is he
convicts us of our sin
you know when the whole light is turned
on sometimes there's pain and there
might be a struggle as a baby's learning
to walk
do not be discouraged linda continue to
keep your eyes fixed on jesus that same
god who helped me give up drugs and
drinking and cursing and all those other
evil things
he who has begun a good work in you will
perform it it doesn't necessarily change
in one day this is called the process of
sanctification yeah absolutely you know
we gain victory step by step and so the
lord leads us and you know i remember
there was a lady that joined our church
one time and she said before i received
christ i thought all i had to do was
stop smoking and i'd be perfect well god
gave a victory over smoke and she
realized wait there's some other things
in life that god is leading me as well
and so our growth in grace is a is a
journey sanctification is the work of a
lifetime we mustn't give up though we
keep pressing towards the mark
absolutely and and there is a battle in
the christian life the battles in life
no matter what you know paul said we
wrestle
we strive
we war
we run
we resist
there is some effort and you know you
want to do uh what you can to avoid
temptation by the way that would be a
good book i think that would be a
blessing for you linda we'll send you a
free book tips on resisting temptation
also talks about how do you get the
victory
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book tips for
resisting temptation the bible says a
righteous man he might fall seven times
but he gets up and so the key is not
giving up keep trusting keep seeking the
lord all things are possible through
christ yeah and the
principle that we see this the apostles
talking about
is growing in grace
we grow in holiness in following the
lord so you what you're sharing linda
thousands out there millions out there
have the same struggle you're not alone
but you can grow in grace it is possible
to be a new creature where old things
are passed away and all things become
new
all right pastor ross i don't think we
have time for another question however
we do want to remind friends we do have
to
say goodbye to those listening on
satellite radio here in just a minute
and a half but for those of you are
watching on amazing facts tv or you're
listening on a land-based radio station
we are going to be coming back with some
rapid fire bible questions and these are
the questions that you have written in
to us here at amazing facts if you have
a bible question we didn't get to it in
the program tonight and if you're
watching on social media you can just
type your bible question right there on
facebook and we'll gather these
questions together and next week we'll
try to answer as many of these questions
as we can after we we take a little
break that's coming up here in about a
minute if you know pasadena we always
like to remind people that there are
many resources available to them for
further study at amazing facts
that's right now if someone wants to
send in a bible question to for next
week uh what's the address for that the
address i've got written down right here
so let me grab it
it's bal questions at amazingfacts.org
and i see they put that on the screen
bal questions amazingfacts.org
and you can send us your question and we
will try and answer it on the air yeah
so we kind of sign off in two stages we
sign off we say
so long arriva derche aloha to our
friends listening on satellite
and then we take two minutes where we're
still on the air and we're going to be
taking bible questions for everybody
else that's listening in and you can
send us those online bible questions
this is where we try to go through it
as quickly as we can it's sort of like a
test rapid fire bible questions but for
all our friends that are out there on
the road or listening on satellite radio
god bless you god willing we will be
back to study his word with you again
next week for the others stand by
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
welcome back friends we got about uh two
and a half minutes left and we're gonna
try to answer as many questions that
have been written into the ministry so
pastor here we go question number one
who does the pregnant woman in the book
of revelation represent
all right now you'll find that in
revelation chapter 12 talks about a
woman standing on the moon clothed with
the sun 12 stars above her head
this is the church of the lord the bride
of christ standing on the moon the
promises of the old testament clothed
with the sun the glory of jesus in the
new testament 12 stars talking about the
leadership
patriarchs in the old testament tribes
apostles in the new testament and
the devil's out to get her and persecute
her and that's what you see the dragons
mad at her
okay next question that we have does the
bible say capital punishment is okay
well you know i don't want to make it
sound like when you say okay i mean sure
let's kill him
but does the bible allow for that and
the answer would have to be a
categorical yes the bible's very clear
that's why jesus died in our place
and so yeah sometimes you've got certain
crimes
that did invite the death penalty
and in the mosaic law not only had the
death penalty it it had the mercy for
different crimes a person might commit
on uh what do you call unintentional
manslaughter and they could flee to a
city of refuge so there's a lot of
justice in the laws that you find god
gave moses okay next question we have is
why is there a wall necessary around the
new jerusalem
yeah walls people think the walls are to
keep enemy armies out
but that's not the only purpose of walls
you might have a a wall around your
house and it's basically a boundary
and so walls can also just point out the
boundary of this is the city of god
and uh there could can be
a different rights within the wall that
you do not have outside the wall this
would be of cities we're going to not
only have a city home jesus built we're
going to have country homes outside the
wall and then of course at the end of
the thousand years when the new
jerusalem comes down the wicked are
resurrected and they're outside the wall
so they do attack from inside they do
their mountain attacks from the city
okay another question we have if we are
saved by faith why does revelation say
that we are judged according to our
works
yeah that's not inconsistent uh your
faith will be seen
in your works this is what james is
saying in chapter two he said you know
we're saved by faith but if you have
faith let me see your faith your faith
will be demonstrated in your behavior
and so
while we are saved by faith and by god's
grace
we're judged by our works because your
works after salvation will demonstrate
whether you really weren't safe
oh you hear the music chasing his
friends we enjoyed this so much we'll
look forward to studying his word with
you again next week god bless you
you